Donald Trump's only Allegiance is to
Donald Trump right we agree on that the
only thing he cares about is Donald
Trump I don't the only thing you care
about I think it's certainly the largest
thing he care it's the largest thing he
cares about right so if you've got a man
who only cares about himself welcome to
politics I mean it's it may be more even
maybe more with Trump but it's certainly
not unique to Trump I think that the
issue with Trump too though is um I
think he's even a threat to the
Republican party in which I think I
think he would mostly agree with me
maybe not overall but on every
individual Point Trump picks bad
candidates he has no concern for the
future of the Republic party like for
instance I think there is a chance I
don't think it'll happen because of how
the polling looks now but if Trump
didn't get the nomination I think Trump
would say screw it and run as an
independent because he thinks he can win
or whatever right um I I doubt that he
would do that but theoretically again
Trump has he was really content to throw
Georgia um the two runoff elections
under the bus because rensburg support
him for the election what what is all
this in service of what's the what's the
generalized argument that you're making
do you believe I'll go back to my
question do you think that if Trump wins
there will be no more elections is that
is that like what what percentage on
what what percentage do you think that
that's a reality ifald Trump wins I
think there is a 100% chance that he
will try to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power in terms of would he
succeed I can guarantee you he will not
do that why is that because he's in his
second term and he's no longer eligible
and he will believe he won and he will
leave yeah but hasn't Donald Trump
himself joked about running for a third
term that's I think that I think that
having a third term what what has Donald
Trump not joked about I mean forgot I
don't okay hold on if you if you want to
prevent if you want to prevent him from
creating a revolution you probably
should actually theed president he again
here's another broad argument that I
don't like in favor of trump and this
was brought up earlier in terms of like
we talk about like not grading
presidents on a curve but then early we
said we take Biden's R I totally grade I
no I 100% grade presidents on a curve
are you kidding oh okay I grade pretty
much everybody on a curve I don't treat
my seven-year-old the same way that I
treat my nine-year-old sure but it feels
like we're treating Donald Trump like a
seven-year-old or a nine-year-old I
think we should treat him like the
president of the United States I don't
think having a president that has taken
like concrete steps to prevent the
transfer of power which he did with the
electorates Shem which you did with
Pence and which you did with trying to
capitalize on the j6 violence a
president that's taken concrete steps
towards cing the government essentially
I don't know why that guy we'd say well
you know it's Trump he does Trump things
the guard rails held we'll probably hold
next time when we say we shouldn't do
you mean that he should be actually
barred from office I'm just talking
about support for him I don't think
Republicans should should support Trump
you lose your incumbent Advantage the
guy's obviously self-destructive he's
destructive the political party itself
like um you think she he should be on
the ballot um you think there's a case
to be made to remove him from the ballot
I think there's a case to be made but
man the phrasing for as much as our uh
governmental founding fathers and
everybody else you know wrote nice
amendments and wrote nice in the
Constitution some of the phrasing is
very very very and the uh section three
um the the the not requiring any type of
actual conviction um I don't have a
strong feeling on it I will say I'm very
interested in reading the majority
opinion from the Supreme Court I
seriously doubt the Supreme Court is
going to uphold that states should be
able to decide if they leave them off
The Ballot or not um I think for the
political future of the United States
stes it's probably not healthy that the
leading opposition candidate is now
going to be barred from the ballot is
probably not healthy for us um cuz
because then what you talk about threats
to democracy that would be a pretty
serious one applied across the board by
it would be however like that threat to
democracy was earned by Donald Trump and
the conservatives that supported him I
think conservatives made a dangerous
gamble when they threw Trump into office
and now like all of the Fallout from
that is is something that we all As
Americans have to deal with I mean I I I
think that the the unprecedented legal
theory that a state can simply Barrow
somebody from the ballot on the basis in
an informal way believing that he is
quote unquote an insurrectionist is is
pretty wild I mean that's that that we
can say it's pretty well but there is an
amendment in the Constitution the 14th
amendment that says that if they have
engaged in this they shall not be or you
shall I don't remember the phrasing
because it doesn't require conviction
but it's a self-executing arguably thing
if we're getting into constitutional law
I mean there there there are a number of
Provisions that that suggest that this
is number one not self-executing
minority opinions in the in the Colorado
Supreme Court case are are pretty
thorough uh the the number one
contention which is that this is not
self-executing uh because other elements
are not self-executing uh that ignores
subsequent actual law that that happened
I mean the Congress passed a law for
example in 1872 defining who was an
insurrectionist who is not an
insurrectionist for perspectives of
elections in 1994 Congress passed a law
that specifically defined Insurrection
as a criminal activity so that somebody
could theoretically be convicted of
insurrection and therefore ineligible to
run for office it is unlike say the the
the analogues that are used by the
majority opinion like age obviously this
is not the same thing we can all tell
what somebody's age is by looking at
their birth certific I can't tell
whether somebody's an insurrectionist
without any reference to a legal statute
or definition of the term I would also
say be careful with that because
remember one of Trump's first like big
political actions was challenging
Obama's birth certificate well and and I
thought that was dumb at the time but I
like that you both said 100% chance that
Trump will try to go for third term and
0% chance which statistic third term
he's done man are you kidding he would
want to Trump's going to walk around
hands up high like I'm a two-term
president I'm the only President since
Grover Cleveland he would know but but
since Grover Cleveland who served two
non-consecutive terms I kicked Joe Biden
out of office and I kicked Hillary
Clinton out of dude would be like he'd
be living large are you kidding he
doesn't want the presidency anymore
after that I just think that the I think
it's scary that like Donald Trump it
feels like for all of the accusations
that are made sometimes against
Democrats like Biden is ordering uh
Garland to investigate Donald Trump and
blah blah blah uh it seems like Donald
Trump would actually do that with his
doj would give them orders he didn't he
didn't he he kind of did though right um
so for instance with um Jeffrey Clark uh
Jeffrey Clark went to Rosen and Donahue
and said Hey listen uh I need you guys
to sign off on a letter that we're going
to use essentially to bully States into
overturning their elections by saying we
found significant election fraud and
part of that threat was Jeffrey Clark
saying listen if you're not going to do
it Rosen uh you know Trump's going to
fire you and just make me the uh acting
attorney general that was a threat that
he carried and I think Trump repeated
that threat in a meeting later on that
was I only rebuked when I think like
half the White House staffs that if you
do this were resigned okay so that's a
slightly different topic because now
you're getting into all the election
Shenanigans and all this but saying he
threatened to fire his acting attorney
general if he wouldn't carry the the
same platform essentially like if Trump
could order his doj to do something
would he um it's not Beyond The Pale for
him right it's not Bey on the pale for
him to order them to do it and then it's
not Beyond The Pale for them to reject
him doing that which is the story of his
entire Administration whereas Joe Biden
orders his doj to do things and then
they just do them well I I'm not we can
get into specifics there um I I just I
it this is one of the big problems that
I have with I mean for example all the
talk about Trump Tyrant Trump executive
power I mean Joe Biden has used
executive power in ways that far
outstrip anything president has been
stretching and stretching and stretching
executive power Jo Joe Biden is going
like Joe Biden has gone well beyond
anything Trump even remotely attempted
to maintain via just pure executive
power and actually Trump's use of
executive power is nowhere near even
what Obama's was in ability to get
border policy pass literally had him
using executive power to to March the
military down to the border to do border
policy I mean I mean Joe Biden literally
used the occupational safety and Hazard
Administration to try to cram down vax
mandates on 80 million Americans that's
insane said cannot Rel student loan debt
and then tried to
Rel hundreds of billions of dollars in
what happened to that it got struck down
by the Supreme Court and then they still
did it they still did it Biden brags
about
it for what he for what he was able to
for what he was able to relieve which I
think were related to particular type
student loan debt but I'm just saying
that like well the guard rails are
holding with Biden as much as they're
holding with Trump the only difference
is is that once Biden you know exhausts
his executive power he's not running
around like lying to people or trying to
extort people or trying to and conco
insane schemes well I mean so here
here's the way I would think of this
think of the guard rails holding as the
filter okay meaning like the the coffee
is in the filter some of it's you know
what you want is going to get through
and all the stuff the guard rails
prevent the other stuff from getting
through now the question becomes what
liquid are you pouring into the filter
okay meaning so if I if I'm if if the
filter exists if the guard rails hold
and if Donald Trump can't steal
elections what's the policy that comes
through the other end of the filter the
policy I get from Donald Trump on the
other end of the filter is a bunch of
stuff that I like the policy that I get
from Joe Biden on the other end of the
filter is a bunch of I don't so
that's the basic calculation okay so so
then the idea is essentially that Donald
Trump's rhetoric is insane but we don't
care um Donald Trump would probably try
to steal an election if he could but he
probably won't be able to um he's not
going to do it again I told you he's not
you don't you don't think he has any why
not because he won't be eligible to be
on the ballot in I mean by the way you
want to talk about 14th Amendment that's
where the 14th amendment applies okay
that that's where it actually applies
meaning you cannot he is not qualified
to be on the ballot in 2028 if he is the
president of the United States states
can Lally in self-executing fashion take
him off the ballot just like he's past
the age of 35 once you have been
president two times you're no longer
eligible to be president of the United
States why have a strong little keep off
the B why the why would the 14th
Amendment stop if he thought vice
president Pence could unilaterally
decide the outcome of the
election when he's not on the ballot so
so now now your theory is that he's
gonna get he's going to get reelected
and then in 2028 he's not even going to
be on the ballot and he's going to
direct his new vice president car Lake
to Simply declare him president of the
United States when he has not been on a
ballot I don't know what the I don't
know what the scheme would be I think we
can kind of like laugh and say there's
no scheme we could even concoct but I
think like with the machine gun he's
going to walk into I think I think the
issue though is that like the idea of
electing another president that has
tried to circumvent the peaceful
transfer power using extra legal means
and then pretending like we can't
concoct a single scheme that he could
try to circumvent um other legal
processes to have a third term or to
have a longer term or to uh install who
he wants as the next president I just
when a when a person has already shown
who they are and with every single
person around him agrees with that when
every single person that's worked with
him save for the what Sydney pal uh
Eastman and juliani which I don't think
even I don't think anybody would want to
throw their lot in with those three um
it just seems wild to me that we would
say like yeah we're just going to go
ahead and trust this guy with another
term in president but like he can't run
for a third term so it's fine when
there's like 50 million other things
I'll make you the case that if you want
him not to make election trouble you
should elect him president in the next
election cycle and then he will be
ineligible that okay well I find that to
be aolly unconvincing argument but
h